NIKOLAI MUNK PETERSEN: The
sky's the limit, they said.
They said your imagination
is the only thing holding you
back.
We discovered that there's
more to this story,
and I'm going to share
with you what we found.
My name is Nikolai,
and when you're
building augmented
reality experiences that
allow users to move
around, you have
to think about real
hard physical limits.
Let's say you have designed
an icy virtual world
for a much anticipated
massively multiplayer online
roleplaying game.
You have only had time to create
one small ice floe and one
main character, the penguin.
Your user lives the penguin life
on the ice with their friends,
but is growing
increasingly frustrated
by the ever-growing
number of penguins.
The user therefore
decides to jump off
the ice to explore new
inhabitable worlds.
What happens next?
The user's room is too small
to fit any more ice floes.
The icy world doesn't scale.
What should the user do?
In this episode, we
will talk about how
to handle physical
boundaries that
obstruct the virtual space.
A very simple but
powerful method
to design around
any kind of boundary
is to put an invisible
fence around the user.
We built a small example
to show you how that works.
The fence serves two purposes.
First, it tells the user
where the virtual world ends.
Second, it helps the user
not walk into physical walls.
Yet it is a fence, and
it does impose rather
direct and hard constraints.
So let's look at some
other gentler ways
to handle physical boundaries.
In mobile devices that
promote physical movement,
such as Project Tango, how
do you take into account
the hard fact of life
that is full of doors
and walls and furniture
that you can bump into,
and how do you leverage
this hard reality
to make stunning
experiences that
deliver on the promise
of seamlessly blending
virtual and physical worlds?
If the virtual world
has a fixed size,
it may or may not fit
within the physical space.
An ice floe may
fit in your room,
while a glacier probably won't.
As a developer,
it's important to be
proactive about
these challenges.
Using a slightly more advanced
version of the fence concept,
you could let the
user define the space
by marking its corners.
In this example, we put
out four markers to fence
off the play space.
The system automatically
fits the virtual world
within the available space.
As an alternative, you can let
the user scan the surroundings
using the depth
perception system
in Project Tango at the
beginning of the experience.
The system can use this 3D
information of the surroundings
to calculate a bounded box
and build the virtual world
within it.
If you do not manage to
fit the virtual world
into the physical,
the user may not
be able to get to all the
places within the world.
For these situations,
the user can
benefit from either the
clutch or teleportation modes.
In clutch mode, the user pauses
motion tracking for a moment.
This effectively pins
the virtual world
to the Project Tango device so
the user can rotate it, like
here, or move it with them.
If the user is facing
a physical wall
with the virtual world
in front of them,
the clutch can be used to rotate
the virtual world around 180
degrees, and by doing
so they can get places
that were out of reach before.
The clutch control is powerful,
but can be a bit complicated
for users, so instead you may
want to try teleportation.
Teleportation petition allows
the user to jump places.
These can be pre-defined
destinations, or in this case,
wherever the user
taps on the screen.
If the virtual
world is large, it
may just be too much
work to walk places.
Teleportation is a great way
to make it easier to get around
faster and with less effort.
Since the boundary between
the experience on screen
and in real life are
starting to blend,
it is important to
think about how to do so
without confusing the user.
Physical boundaries
can prevent the user
from entering virtual places.
Virtual boundaries
can cause the user
to accidentally exit
virtual places, which
we will cover in the designing
for virtual boundaries episode.
To create phenomenal
experiences,
you must be mindful of
the boundaries that exist
and handle them seamlessly.
Visit our Google+ community
and join us in our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]